how important is your result here in the
race to London good result in classical
will will go a long way towards deciding
who goes to London I think it's still
very much up in the air like Magnus's is
pretty much for sure there but a lot of
players have have chances besides him I
would say that it's my last chance
because I didn't play well in in Abidjan
and he and also in Croatia I had a lot
of chances
I could win three or four games but I
didn't win any single game so basically
if I don't play well and in single tap
then I lost my chance yeah in general
I'm quite in good shape
after Paris in the single Cup it should
be alright for me to qualify for zone
for London even though that would be my
last event so I loved some of the
players will have two events to to catch
up with me yes very important since
there are only three tournaments ahead
and in America we have will compete in
total Monroe so my doctor after we get
back I wouldn't know if I still had some
chance to get to London if I managed to
achieve a good result in both
tournaments then I can relax about the
next event so I think that that would be
a good thing to do
I played badly in the rapid and blitz
event and I was not very fortunate that
actually in that tournament there were
not so many people collapsing unlike in
the San Luis here when you had many
people going on
gigantic losing streaks now I have to
probably do very well in the classical
event and yeah I mean I'm certainly
looking forward to give it a shot here
again is a very important every
tournaments and of course also is this
tournament it will be my last closing
tournaments in this year and
in classical chest and I want to play
very good here and after think about
history every point Ranchester point is
huge in terms of qualification every
half point even but this classical
tournament is huge because if you win
first place you get 20 points and that
basically guarantees your qualification
to London so for instance if Fabiano
wins this tournament their first he's
probably gonna make it to London but if
Magnus means it's their first and he'll
just take all the points from everybody
because I think is pretty much going to
make it to London I think if I play
blindfolded I will qualify for London
and so I think that's it there st. Louis
the classical events are the single
biggest or of points obviously I still
have to rapid in blitz events left which
is nice in November but without a good
performance here it's not gonna help a
lot so I really need a good performance
here to still be in contention I think
if I want to qualify for London I should
and like in top free here so I think
that's all about it and of course the
better you play the more points you get
I can't play badly here if I want to
qualify for London but to tell the truth
- if I really want to go to London
because it's like 15 tournaments this
year if we were together we found a
little bit too much
[Music]